os advertimos que este vídeo puede herir
vuestra sensibilidad y provocamos una
fuerte sensación de indignación en el os
vamos a hablar de la que tal vez sea la
casa real con comportamientos más
reprobables y despóticos de todo el
mundo os vamos a contar como un sultán
ha convertido a su pueblo en una especie
de vaca lechera a la que ordena sin
tregua si estás listo arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os pregunto por un país del sudeste
asiático que no sea singapur y que tenga
un pib per cápita similar al de españa o
corea del sur que países ocurre seguro
que muy pocos habréis pensado en brunei
o al menos seríais pocos si no hubieses
leído el título de este vídeo es posible
que la inmensa mayoría apenas hayáis
oído hablar de este pequeño país
enclavado en la isla de borneo y rodeado
por territorios pertenecientes a la
federación malasia al fin y al cabo no
sólo es pequeño en territorio sino
también en población el oficialmente
conocido como estado de brunei
darussalam no llega ni siquiera al medio
millón de habitantes
no es un país muy conocido pero con ello
es uno de los países con más riquezas en
relación a sus habitantes de todo el
mundo sus reservas de petróleo y de gas
son en términos relativos inmensas y el
sultán hassanal bolkiah ha sabido
aprovecharlas el petróleo y el gas
natural licuado que también procesan
generan más de la mitad del pib además
la mayoría de estos recursos se extraen
de su zona económica exclusiva en el mar
con lo que bruna y goza de uno de los
entornos naturales mejor conservados
mundo
[Música]
suena bien verdad pues espera un momento
porque ya sabéis eso de que no es oro
todo lo que reluce ni plata todo lo que
brilla y en este caso no podría ser más
claro
[Aplausos]
y es que a pesar de ser un país tan rico
lo cierto es que los brunos gozan de un
nivel de vida más bien justito y eso si
hablamos de la cartera porque si lo
hacemos de libertades o derechos humanos
la cosa en este país asiático es que
esté mal es que además no para de
empeorar pero dicho esto estoy seguro de
que os han surgido unas cuantas
preguntas si este es un trato es
aparentemente tan rico a dónde va todo
el dinero que no llegan a ver los
ciudadanos de brunei que está pasando
políticamente en el país para que al
revés que en la mayor parte del mundo
los derechos y libertades aquí estén en
retroceso pues amigos en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a estas dos preguntas
y os vamos a contar algunas cosas sobre
las excentricidades más locas y la
deriva más totalitaria del señor sultán
preparados pues bien viajamos hasta
brunei
[Música]
el sultanato del derroche es la que vais
a ver a continuación es una historia que
parece sacada de toda una película de
hollywood ya sabéis una de esas
historias de sultanes multimillonarios
que se rodean de los lujos más
extravagantes que podáis imaginar y que
incluso tienen un harén de mujeres para
ello solos pues bien algo parecido a eso
es lo que se ha convertido la casa real
de brunei una casa real a la que no sólo
le gusta tener sino que además le gusta
enseñar fijaos por ejemplo en la
limusina dorada rolls royce de 14
millones de dólares que tiene el sultán
hassanal y no no penséis que es el único
coche caro que guarda su garaje no para
nada de hecho se calcula ojo que son más
de 7000 los vehículos que tiene a su
disposición la casa real
hablamos de una flota con un valor
estimado de unos 5 mil millones de
dólares sólo en coches y si habéis
escuchado bien 5.000 millones de dólares
claro que hablamos de un sultán cuyo
patrimonio está valorado en más de 20
mil millones para que os hagáis una idea
esta es una cifra muy superior a la de
todo el producto interior bruto del país
es más si tenemos en cuenta que el pib
del país viene a ser de unos 13.500
millones esto quiere decir que la
fortuna del sultán es casi un 50 por
ciento mayor esto sería el equivalente a
que he hecho que se por ejemplo la casa
real británica maneja a ser un
patrimonio de casi 4 billones más que
todo el pei de alemania de locos
entre el inmenso inventario que compone
el patrimonio del sultán podemos
encontrar 10 yates de lujo al menos 17
aviones y más de 150 mansiones en 12
países diferentes y eso eso no es todo
porque si no fuese suficientemente
muestra de ostentación y lujo que este
sultán vive en el palacio privado más
grande del mundo un palacio que cuenta
con ni más ni menos que mil 788
habitaciones doscientos cincuenta y
siete cuartos de baño cinco piscinas su
propia mezquita privada y un garaje para
110 de sus miles de coches entre otras
muchas instalaciones por ejemplo todo el
palacio está forrado con 38 tipos de
mármoles italianos granito de shanghai
cristales ingleses y decoraciones de
seda india en otras palabras hablamos de
un tipo que no escatima en lujos para
que os hagáis una idea durante sus días
más desenfrenados cuando era un poquito
más joven se calcula que durante diez
años este sultán se gastó casi 750 mil
dólares diarios y nos estamos refiriendo
a dólares de eeuu
[Música]
claro que no solo tienen bienes de lujo
este es un tanto también tiene su faceta
empresarial y por ejemplo por tener
tiene hasta su propia cadena hotelera
bueno técnicamente la cadena de
dorchester collection es propiedad del
fondo soberano del país un fondo que a
su vez depende del ministerio de
finanzas que o sorpresa sorpresa lo
dirige el propio sultán hassanal digamos
que en brunei no hay ninguna diferencia
entre el patrimonio público y el
patrimonio de la casa real bueno mejor
dicho en este sultanato el patrimonio
público pertenece a la casa real por
supuesto toda esta inmensa fortuna no
sólo es disfrutada por el señor sultán
sino también por su propia familia que
por cierto no tienen ningún pudor en
exhibir esa riqueza en redes sociales de
hecho su décimo hijo es toda una
estrella de instagram con más de dos
millones de seguidores en esta red
social el joven martín de apenas 29 años
no se corta un pelo en mostrar sus
vuelos en helicópteros sus lanzamientos
en paracaídas sus paseos en yate
al polo o sus viajes por el mundo en 10
privado oye desde luego hay que
reconocer que productivos esta gente son
un rato porque madre mía todo lo que
consiguen hacer es que eso sí que es
estirar el tiempo pero amigos por
supuesto no avisó al político es un
programa del corazón si os contamos
todas estas cosas es simple y llanamente
para situarnos un poco mejor porque
tener una cosa presente brunei no es un
país cualquiera su sultán tampoco rafa
nadal está considerado como uno de los
últimos monarcas absolutistas del siglo
21 y el segundo rey que más tiempo lleva
reinando sólo le supera la reina de
inglaterra para que os hagáis una idea
llevan el trono desde 1967 yo juego
porque no sólo es el sultán también
ostenta los cargos de primer ministro
ministro de defensa ministro de finanzas
y ministro de exteriores y bueno quién
sabe igualmente os hacemos este vídeo se
ha puesto a cargo de un nuevo ministerio
estamos que el gobierno es él
os imaginais una reunión del gobierno
vamos me da que en el ministerio de
defensa de exteriores y de finanzas muy
en desacuerdo no están porque vamos cómo
vas a estar en desacuerdo contigo mismo
en fin toda una muestra de lo que
significa el poder absoluto ahora bien
llegados a este punto seguro que muchos
estaréis pensando vale este hombre pues
debe ser el típico déspota que se baña
en billetes por las noches y tiene a su
pueblo muerto de hambre verdad pues lo
cierto es que no al menos no del todo
[Música]
y es que el sistema económico
desarrollado en brunei es de todo menos
común brunei es la definición del libro
de un estado de bienestar rentista
explicó la casa real y bruna y compra la
fidelidad y el silencio del pueblo a
cambio de ciertos servicios que por
supuesto son minucias en comparación con
la potencial riqueza de la que deberían
disfrutar sus ciudadanos teniendo en
cuenta las inmensas riquezas del país
pero como lo hacen pues fijaos
[Música]
básicamente el gobierno de brunei
utiliza una pequeña parte de sus rentas
petroleras y gaseras para garantizar que
no le falte lo básico a sus 460 mil
habitantes y el resto pues el resto se
lo quedan para ellos digamos que de esta
forma pueden seguir viviendo como dioses
sin arriesgarse a que el pueblo se
revele por el hambre o la pobreza o
pongan en cuestión los comportamientos
poco éticos de sus dirigentes bueno
estas prebendas y también mano dura
porque hay quien brunei si una cosa está
prohibida ante todas las demás es
precisamente hablar mal de la familia
real
[Música]
y ojo porque cuando decimos que los
ciudadanos de brunei reciben lo básico
queremos decir básicamente una vivienda
y un coche y allí están subsidiados con
préstamos a tipos bajísimos también
sanidad dentista gratuitos educación
gratuita y pensiones de vejez incluso tu
funeral lo subsidia el gobierno eso sí
no penséis en una sanidad o una
educación de altísima calidad al
gobierno le gusta ahorrar es una
cuestión digestivos cuanto más dinero
sobre más se meten en el bolsillo
[Música]
y amigos puede que esta descripción no
sea técnicamente precisa pero la
práctica es así cómo funcionan las cosas
en este lugar hablamos de un país en el
que los ciudadanos se han vuelto muy
dependientes de las rentas del estado y
por consiguiente de lo que se le antoje
al sultán darles pero cuyo nivel de vida
no se aproxima ni ve lejos al de los
países desarrollados y además claro todo
esto de lo gratuito al final siempre
tiene un precio y en el caso de brunei
es alto precio es el de la libertad los
derechos humanos y la práctica
imposibilidad de ascender en la escala
social si no perteneces a las clases
altas más pudientes que mantienen
estrechos lazos estrechos nexos con la
casa real y eso eso es lo que explica
que en 2019 nos encontremos titulares
como este el nuevo código penal de
brunei consagraría castigos crueles
inhumanos advierte la jefa de derechos
humanos de la onu ahora bien qué narices
está pasando con la política en brunei y
para que hasta la mismísima aunque
siempre se pone de perfil todo ponga su
grito en el cielo que es eso tan grave
que el sultanato ha decidido castigar de
forma cruel
inhumana pues bien veámoslo
es la mismo vídeo e hipocresía
brunei es un país de mayoría musulmana
aproximadamente tres de cada cuatro
habitantes son musulmanes el resto se
reparten entre una amalgama de
cristianos budistas y creencias
indígenas pero a pesar de que una de
cada cuatro personas no es musulmana el
país lleva desde el 2014 introduciendo
en su código penal- reformas y castigos
de la ley islámica la 'sharia' idea que
empezó a rondarle por la cabeza al
sultán hassanal a finales de los 90 y
que a la mayoría de sus habitantes no le
pareció nada mal aunque visto lo visto
hubiera dado igual amigos queréis saber
más sobre magnéticas ideas pues
agarrados a la silla
[Música]
las reformas que se comenzaron a
implementar en 2014 se completaron en
abril de 2019 en ella se establece que
las relaciones sexuales consensuadas
entre hombres supone la pena de muerte
por lapidación es que son entre mujeres
están penadas con hasta 40 golpes con
vara o hasta 10 años de cárcel y para
los ladrones impuestos la amputación de
extremidades empezando por la mano
derecha y siguiendo por el pie izquierdo
si reinciden
es decir el sultanato de brunei completó
el pasado año 2019 lo que supone el
establecimiento estricto de la sharia en
el país en un entorno en el que ningún
país musulmán vecino ha establecido las
penas capitales para este tipo de
comportamientos
ya lo veis de este modo luna se ha
convertido en el único país del sudeste
asiático e imponer una visión estricta
de la ley islámica al más puro estilo de
afganistán arabia saudí o irán
[Música]
eso sí hasta la fecha alguna y todavía
no ha aplicado la pena capital para
ninguno de estos casos y de hecho lleva
sin ejecutar a nadie desde el año 1957
cuando todavía brunei era un
protectorado británico pero el hecho de
que lo hayan añadido en su código penal-
lanza una peligrosa advertencia el poder
del sultán está por encima de todas las
cosas y seguirá siendo el garante de la
pureza del islam y de la aplicación de
su ley en su versión más integrista pero
esperando un momento porque con todo
esto seguro que muchos estaréis pensando
valen
a ver si el sultán es tan devoto del
islam entonces entiendo que deberá vivir
como manda la tradición islámica no pues
lo cierto es que no de hecho más bien
todo lo contrario no sólo por su
lujosísimo tren divide sus riquezas oye
contrarias a la humildad que promulga el
islam sino también por sus
comportamientos personales y es que
veréis tanto hassanal como su hermano
jeffrey tienen una vida un poco como
decirlo polémica tan polémica como de
sobra conocida en todo el mundo
por ejemplo no son pocas las mujeres que
han asegurado haber formado parte de una
especie de harén personal del hermano
del sultán con decenas de ellas alojadas
dentro del recinto del propio palacio y
semi encerrada sin poder comunicarse
mujeres que en muchas ocasiones también
o sorpresa sorpresa tenían relaciones
con resultan de hecho lineal loren una
de las que fueran chicas del harén
cuenta su experiencia en su libro
algunas chicas en donde relata cómo fue
su vida por esos lares y como las
utilizaban y desechaban a su antojo
tienen más dinero que nadie sé que ambos
el sultán y jeffrey se han casado y
divorciado multitud de ocasiones es
realmente hipócrita gillian lauren y es
que de hecho no le falta razón mientras
el sultán de brunei también impone la
pena capital por lapidación al adulterio
en y su hermanos han estado corriendo
unas juergas locas con decenas cientos
de mujeres occidentales durante años de
hecho otra mujer shannon marketing miss
eeuu en el 92 llegó a denunciar al
sultán en un tribunal de los eeuu al
final
desestimó la denuncia por su inmunidad
como jefe de estado sin embargo todo
esto le sirvió para que se hiciera
famosa su historia en la que relató por
ejemplo que aceptó un trabajo en brunei
word 3000 dólares al día que acabó
resultando ser de semiesclava para la
hermana de sultán jeffrey y para el
mismo sultán en el wok
[Música]
pero no penséis que son estos dos
personajes los únicos juerguistas
metidos en escándalos que suelen
terminar siempre con un derroche de
dinero digamos poco ético es que hay más
otro hermano del sultán mohammed bolkiah
que supuestamente detestaba en el
derroche de hassan al jeffrey cuando
dejó de ser ministro de asuntos
exteriores y convierte en año 2015
recibió un finiquito de dos mil millones
de dólares sin rechistar pero saber
quién le va a decir que no a 2.000
millones el caso es que la opulencia de
la familia real y su comportamiento
totalmente opuesto al islam les
convierte probablemente en uno de los
gobiernos más hipócritas del panorama
internacional y entonces si a todo esto
le sumamos el estancamiento social por
su modelo rentista la falta de
libertades el incumplimiento de los
derechos humanos más básicos y una
familia real bañada en riquezas y vicios
e hipocresía lo que nos sale es ni más
ni menos que brunei pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti qué opinas de este
curioso sistema por el que las leyes
liberticidas se aplican sólo a la
ciudadanía pero no
la realeza podra bruna y progresar
mientras una buena parte de sus ingresos
de hidrocarburos va a parar directamente
a la casa real como siempre deja nuestra
opinión aquí abajo en los comentarios y
si te resulta interesante este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a nuestro canal para estar a
la última de todo una vez más un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]